desde España el presidente de Guatemala
Alejandro yamaté llamó a la cordura su
homólogo colombiano Gustavo Petro al
argumentar que los diferentes entre dos
naciones se deben resolver por la vía
diplomática de las cancillerías para
evitar que estos conflictos escalen a
estadios de los cuales no se puede
retornar según Diamante y el anuncio de
ayer de parte de la fe y la fiscalía
especial contra la impunidad en
Guatemala en relación con el ministro
colombiano Iván Velázquez corresponde a
la apertura de una investigación en su
contra por supuestos actos ilegítimos
arbitrarios abusivos cuando él se
encontraba como jefe de la Sisi en una
investigación de El entramado de
odebrecht pero aclaró llamate que una
investigación es muy distinto a una
persecución penal política y que hasta
el momento no se ha emitido ninguna
orden de captura en contra del
colombiano pero que la respuesta
colombiana Sí fue innecesaria de llamar
a consultas a su embajadora Por lo cual
Guatemala se ve obligado a hacer lo
mismo pero que retirar a las embajadoras
de sus respectivas embajadas pone a las
dos naciones al borde del rompimiento se
espera entonces que muy pronto se sepa
de qué se trata la formulación de esta
fiscalía guatemalteca de que emprenderá
acciones judiciales en contra de el
ministro colombiano Iván Velázquez
Aunque cabe aclarar que Telma Aldana
exfiscal Guatemalteca exiliada en los
Estados Unidos que trabajó en llave con
Iván Velázquez ayer sí le fue notificada
una orden de captura por relación a este
mismo caso que cobija a el colombiano